and every country I've looked at
women turning 30 without a child only
have a 50 50 chance of ever becoming a
mother
30.
and when I asked people on a survey what
age do you think it's 50 50. 40 was the
most common answer do we have any sort
of sense of why it is for the first time
in in probably human history we are
we're whittling down our own Society do
we have an idea of what that is well to
go back to the these triggers the oil
shock the mortgage shock Etc also in
Korea the the um the currency crisis of
the mid 90s there's multiple examples of
this what what you find is a very quick
transition to high childlessness but it
never goes back so it locks in so the
question it could talk about the culture
around this
societal Norms change
in some way
that lock in a new pattern and that
pattern is one where people have
children later so I I think what's
happened is frankly
um as societies and this is
cross-cultural I mean you look at Japan
as a culture you look at Europe
different parts of Europe the US even
Brazil is suffering from the exact same
problem even Russia
um on your grade so you look at all of
these places and you find that across
all these cultures once people start
delaying Parenthood it gets locked in
and I I equate this a little bit in in
Japan we have words for this
um the the person who was hired a little
a year or two before you is called
senpai
so everyone has a senpai and Senpai has
a senpai and then the people below you
are like kohai so it helps me with this
terminology if you're a particularly a
woman and you've just turned 30 and
you're Senpai and Senpai Senpai have not
had a child yet you're a feeling as well
it's probably not my time yet because I
might be perceived as you know so you're
not even thinking of it and what you
might be thinking is well when Senpai
Senpai boss's boss has a child then
there'll be a promotional opportunity so
I'm gonna wait for that so I think the
way you know the world kind of welcomes
people
um to kind of delay parenting around
this so it becomes a cultural phenomenon
but yeah yeah it's cross-cultural if
that makes sense that makes perfect
sense so essentially we're
once you've had the transition from
having children young to not having
children young it becomes a locked in
cultural phenomenon that people
essentially mimetically take on from
others around them and then you add to
that the economic rationale for well
I'll get my career sorted first then
we'll have kids and because of that as
you say 80 of the women who end up being
childless did not intend to be childless
in countries have gone through the full
transition yeah so in the US there's a
lot of women right now hoping to become
a mother who are aged you know 35 to
early 40s and just statistically you
just look at the the chances are are not
high I mean that's one other fact just I
I love sharing if I clean that in every
country except one and the one is Israel
I'll talk about in a moment and every
country I've looked at
woman turning 30 without a child only
have a 50 50 chance of ever becoming a
mother
30. in the Israel that's 31 it's just a
little bit older
and when I asked people on the survey
what age do you think it's 50 50. 40 was
the most common answer so again we have
this mismatch about what is possible
what we're not aware of for whatever
reason is that women's fertility a Falls
much faster than expected that there's a
lot of variability in it some people
some women are very fertile to 40 or
older some lose their fertility by age
30. so we don't know about that
variation like they're there for the
risk also we don't know that the quality
of a woman's eggs a woman is born with
all of the eggs she will ever have in
her life women do not make new eggs
so two things happen during that time
and it's covered in a documentary of Kim
Kardashian's uh uh fertility doctor uh
include to explain how this happens you
lose both the count of eggs but you also
lose the quality of eggs and then a
third thing happens which is the ability
to carry a baby to term the risks
associated with that go up so
um to be honest with you and you'll see
it in part two of the documentary which
is not quite out yet a little bit in
part one where I started asking women in
their 40s and 50s without children had
the intended to have children and it was
a very delicate subject and I have to be
I have to say people watching this in
the situation
these are people internally grieving the
fact that they had never families and
you see deeply emotional scenes
and it's heartbreaking is absolutely
heartbreaking it's
you know something that I think we
should know more about
um as a society you know just the fact
that we've got to be sensitive to people
so just to give you an example
um some people perhaps many
[Music]
um
who don't have children in the workplace
will see a colleague bringing their
child to work or talking about their
children many of these people go to
Pieces when this happens they'll go to
the restroom they'll go to the toilet
and just stay there they'll go and you
know have a walk we don't realize that
certainly I didn't the internal anguish
that happens so to your point
um Society I agree is not informing
people men or women because men are
trying to partner with women if they
want kids who are able to have children
men also are in the dark here we talked
about fertility but fertility is not the
biggest reason people aren't becoming
parents it's because they they're not
with a partner at that right time
so they're working on their career 32-33
maybe they do have a partner at that
time now everything's good for one of
them but maybe the other partner isn't
quite ready
or maybe there's a breakup or a divorce
or maybe you actually don't have a
boyfriend girlfriend partner at that
time not having a partner at the right
time is the biggest reason and that's
why I wanted to tell people that you're
at Cambridge was that you know like one
of the comments and I think Varsity
Magazine from one student a medical
student was that they don't need to be
told whether they want their children or
not what I want to tell them is actually
it takes two to have a child and finding
a partner at the right time is there for
really important and most people skip
over that you know I we've talked a lot
about women
becoming unplanned jealous but it
happens to men too and how it happens to
men is we think we can wait and wait and
wait because technically mostly we're
able to have children later than women
but do you know what happens age 45
you're competing with a 35 year old
version of yourself to find the same
woman who's able to have children so
there are actually more childless men
than childless women
and I think men need to understand that
this applies to them just as much
foreign